I'm going try to divide this up into a
few pieces okay first just because I
didn't parameter although you don't
remember what is a rational function
apart from the example in Matt's
rational doesn't mean sensible it means
to do with ratios okay so essentially a
rational function is just a function
which has a fraction in it you can't
resolve the cockpit root of you can't
simplify out okay so you're gonna look
at a whole bunch of examples I've got a
four step process to graph any rational
function okay and if I try and make
corny acronyms for all my things okay so
we're going to get to the corny acronym
sue but first I thought I'd tell you
what a couple of the harder parts the
affair of that and then we'll put it all
together okay so the first something you
should make is asymptotes okay you know
asymptotes and asymptotic behavior years
so we want to work out how do we find
where the asymptotes of a rational
function are because you need to know
where they are so you can when your
graph looks like okay so there are three
kinds of asymptote right three quick
types and you may like to draw yourself
here a little table okay what are the
three kinds if you've got vertical ones
right vertical and then you've got
horizontal ones
and then you've got the reader ones
which are really a pain of the leaked
ones okay so going up down going across
and then the ones which offer an angle
okay now you can actually tell before
you even start really working with a
rational function immediately which
one's a graph is going to have to
capture let's think about this how can
you tell what a vertical asymptote what
is a vertical asymptote come from okay
let's think about some examples things
like this y equals 1 over X where's the
vertical asymptote it's at x equals zero
now if I just change this a little bit
what effect does that have on the
vertical asymptote it moves it over now
the vertical asymptote is x equals 1
okay how do I get the vertical asymptote
what if I made it something like say x
squared minus 1 hmm the simple way of
working out number one do you have a
vertical asymptote because they don't
all have is there a vocalist two is can
the denominator sorry test can the
denominator equal zero
okay can the denominator equal zero so
for instance if I change this right
let's make it x squared plus one x
squared plus one look at the denominator
x squared plus one can it equal to zero
okay equal to zero in common right
because you can't find any real values
that satisfy that equation so Y goes one
on XK plus one has no vertical
asymptotes even though it's a rational
function okay all right so keep that in
your mind you look at Matt think about
horizontal and oblique asymptotes okay
I'm actually going to want these
together okay because a vertical
asymptote means it's a question of
domain right okay because at a vertical
asymptote the graph cannot exist when
you put such a value in it breaks the
function because you are dividing by
zero okay horizontal oblique asymptotes
are very very different denied that
domain they tell you what happens at the
far ends of the graph the far ends of
the graph
nobody's saying that is the extremities
right so at positive and negative
infinity okay so coming back to that
first one
y equals whatever it is right what is
the well it's gonna it's gonna
horizontal asymptote at y equals zero
right now when you look at this graph
very quickly right rough okay now why in
that acetone whack was here it doesn't
tell you anything about what the graphs
to e in the middle the graph ignores the
asymptotes in the middle okay it's like
running off over here and down there
okay and it's the same with oblique
asymptotes okay
so that's why sometimes we're gonna do
so graphs where you've got say an
asymptote like that
and the graph will cross it like that
okay you thought but wait asymptotes you
come across asymptotes you can't cross
vertical ass
because they can't exist there right
horizontal oblique asymptote you cross
small time make a [ __ ] you can make up a
function that across the answer to an
infinite number of times because it just
tells you that the ends not about the
middle how do you know if it's got a
horizontal pour in oblique asymptotes
okay for instance I can tell you right
now without doing any work but that will
have a horizontal asymptote I'm not
gonna bleed gases well I can say that
this will still have a horizontal
asymptote but this will have an oblique
one right yeah just okay so degree this
is exactly the right word degree what is
degree mean when you have a polynomial
like say 1 minus X cubed degree D means
what's the highest power you can get to
okay so this one man is executed to you
right I can head on all these other
weird things over on the end whatever
okay the highest power is still 3 so the
degree of the numerator here is 3 the
degree of the dominant denominator is 2
okay now I'm gonna give you the test for
whether something is horizontal or
oblique okay think about the degree of
the numerator and compare it to the
denominator okay so I'm going to call
that degree of the numerator okay and
the degree of the denominator
what's a horizontal asymptote me I Ament
you're going towards one concrete value
okay
so if these two degrees are equal answer
I've got let's let's go back here say x
squared minus 1 and x squared plus 1
remember all you're talking about it's
about the ends what happened there are
really huge numbers involved okay
so I've got like x equals a million for
x equals minus a million see this minus
one and this plus one well anyone else
that's in a vicinity to be honest okay
when you're a big values like plus or
minus a million these guys become
insignificant okay because this guy
takes over that degree takes over does
that make sense now seeing as the
degrees are equal these two things
though they look very different and the
infinities they approach the same thing
they both approach a million squared or
a billion squared over a million square
billion square okay so what will these
things approachable in that case it'll
be one does that make sense because
there are protein the same thing what if
I changed it what if I stuck a two at
the front of that two x squared well
this is approaching a million squared
times two and this is approaching a
million square right that's what it's
getting to at the ends right so the
whole thing will just be towards two so
if the degrees are equal you will get a
horizontal passage the hon was it a very
first example I gave you it has a
horizontal asymptote but the degrees are
not equal
the degree of the numerator is less than
the degree of the denominator okay now
what is this give us a horizontal
asymptote and actually gives us a
special horizontal axis right
what if I said let's make it know that
and then change this when the degrees
are different okay so this is sort of a
subset of horizontal okay when the
degree of the numerator is less than the
degree of the denominator what happens
what does 1 over X approach approaches 0
this also approaches 0 and so does this
and so does this they all approach 0
murmurs okay I'm not sure remember I
keep on emphasizing it's about the
extremities right so what happens when
you put in a million okay this thing's
getting big it's getting a big fast
right but this one's always gonna get
the faster okay so it's a large number
over an in comprehensively larger number
right so I don't care how big this is
this guy is just going to tack on it
around get me into a head mark and then
you know thank you so you know you get
the idea this thing that the numerator
is always going to get beaten by the
denominator so when the degree of the
numerator is less than the degree of the
denominator
you still get a horizontal asymptote but
you get a particular one namely you get
x equals zero I saw your wife thank you
it's always Mike for something so um
these are both horizontal right what
would you get here you get y equals some
kind of constant like we looked at 1 or
2 or 3 or minus 50 okay all right you
guys smart you guys are good beats I
looked at the degrees and the numerator
the denominator what do you think is
gonna go down here when the degree of
the numerator is bigger
okay so let's kind of a bit about Miss
here if we go with X cubed over 1 minus
X square as I go off to the infinities
okay
this numbers going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and would be much
bigger than this however big it is okay
so therefore it's increasing it's not
going towards one number I can put more
numbers in and it will keep on
increasing forever okay so that's why
okay you're gonna get graphs that do
that see they're just gonna keep on
getting bigger they're like I'm not
gonna approach a value like that I'm
just gonna keep on keep on going so this
is how you can tell now that's how you
know which kind of a century we've got
but how do you work out what the
acetones okay I sort of already showed
you with the vertical one you make the
denominator equal zero and that'll spit
out the equations of any vertical
asymptotes but for the horizontal ones
right if the degrees of the numerator is
less you don't have to do any work you
just say it's zero if the degrees are
equal what do you look for the
coefficients specifically the leading
coefficient y equals right what's that
going to approach you ignore all the
other ones except for the ones with the
degree that's gonna be three times a
million squared over two times a million
squared it'll be three over two is that
make sense you don't have to do that
much work you can just see it on there
so that's how you get that to get that
the person hurts how do you find a
diptych asymptote you have to divide
you've got no other choice which is
painful I admit but hopefully if people
have been thinking carefully for you the
equations won't be too bad so let's just
do a quick example x squared minus I'll
put another plus 2 all over X minus plus
3 all right so I know there's an oblique
asymptote because degree is 2 & 1 okay
so just to refresh you in case you don't
remember how to long divide you stick
your divisor up there and you stick your
outer circle down what this is called
dividend dividends yes questions up
here's this video gaming and then what
do you do you treated just like long
division of the numbers so you say how
many times is X going to x squared
that's up x times then you multiply back
okay then I you subtract right so minus
X minus 3x is minus 4x okay then you do
it all the beginning - swampy okay now
usually you'd keep on going okay because
you want to find out what the remainder
is however because all we try to do is
find an asymptote right this is actually
far enough because watch this rate what
I'm saying is x squared minus X plus 2
is equal to X plus 3 X minus 4 and some
remained on ok but have a look at what
I'm actually looking for here the graph
right it's this over X plus 3 which is
this turbine X plus 3 and this omen X
plus 2
don't forget this is a constant number
like 250
cancel cancel X minus four plus
remainder now what a horizontal oblique
asymptotes about keep on asking you this
they're about extremities okay so you
put in huge numbers for X what's gonna
happen to this guy
you have your vanish okay and there's
your oblique asymptote so we hate long
division but at least we don't have to
do all of it to find out what the actual
asymptote is okay all right that's
asymptotes does that make sense is there
any questions